rwanda's famously Rich volcanic red soil
turned over by shovels and garden tools
revealing a family secret hidden for
three
decades shards of bone teeth
skulls yet another Mass grave from the
1994 genocide it was discovered beneath
a home in the village of Ena it's
believed the family knew what was
underneath five of them have been
arrested on suspicion of complicity in
genocide and concealing evidence for the
community around them it's
horrifying we found so many bodies under
the house and we are still finding more
can you imagine them building a house
where they sleep and knowing for 30
years that there are bodies under them
and never saying anything rwanda's
genocide saw 800,000 ethnic tootsies but
also moderate ethnic hus killed by
members of the hu majority years later
survivors are still searching for their
loved ones shoes and tattered clothing
carry important
Clues we tried to ask those centers for
genocide crimes to tell us where the
bodies are located because we didn't
want to find them in a farm not buried
it's unfortunate that after 30 years we
still found bodies under construction
sites we feel bad and we keep thinking
about what
happened the biggest challenge is
getting Those who commit the killings to
reveal the locations of these Graves
they're still being found regularly
across the country the remains of more
than 100,000 genocide victims have been
Unearthed in the past 5 years alone in
Ina they're not sure how many victims
are buried here the mayor says the
deeper they dig the more they find
Alexander buers Al jazer
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer